merci président messieurs en tout cas je
vous remercie pour les quelques éléments
de langage que que j'ai pu retenir tout
à l'heure puisque cet après-midi les les
pêcheurs et représentants de pêcheurs
guyanais il y aura des mères puis les
parlementaires nous aurons une réunion
avec monsieur le ministre et outre-mer
pour justement évoqué la question de la
pêche illégale pas seulement sur le plan
maritime aussi sur le plan fluvial
puisqu'en ce moment les pêcheurs
guyanais subissent des choses qui sont
vraiment difficile à vivre alors moi
j'ai quelques questions donc sur les
enjeux économiques quels sont les freins
au développement de la filière aquacole
en outre-mer et comment y remédier
s'agissant de la tech quelles actions et
youri terre doivent être conduites pour
assurer l'avenir de cette filière tout
particulièrement en guyane sens de la
pêche quelle action prioritaire doit
être conduite pour assurer assurée par
dont l'avenir de cette filière
le premier mais je pense que nos amis
pêcheurs guyanais que vous avez
rencontrées vous le diront c'est
l'attractivité du métier qui est souvent
mal connu ou alors quand il est connu il
est n'est pas appréciée parce que les
conditions d'embarquement les outils
pour pêcher ne sont pas adaptés sont
vieillissants je me souviens d'un
déplacement qu'on a effectués en guyane
il ya quelques années
où on avait pu visiter à quai une
tapouilles
je peux vous rassure vous assurer que
les vous montrer ça demain un jeune qui
se destinent au monde de la pêche je
suis pas sûr qu'ils souhaitent embarquer
pour quelques mares et dans les
conditions sanitaires et jumelles en mer
pour quelques jours et avec une une
valorisation salariale qui a ses limites
et on regarde la ressource qui est
ramené
la deuxième question la troisième
question ça des questions des formations
qui sont disponibles sur le territoire
cinquième point c'est la capacité
d'export vers l'international ou vers
l'union européenne continentale
notamment en prenant en compte la
question des certificats sanitaires
il ya certaines espèces qu'on pêche en
outre mer qu'on ne peut pas exporter
vers l'hexagone qu'on ne peut pas
exporter vers l'union européenne
continental ou même vers l'international
et c'est dommage que ce sont des espèces
qui sont pêchés dans ces territoires et
qui pourrait tout à fait abonder les
marchés de l'hexagone ou encore une fois
de l'union européenne ou de houe de
l'international il faut également
continuer à croître la lutte contre la
pêche illégale
je parle spécifiquement de la guyane
mais je pense que c'est des discussions
où vous pourrez avoir tout à l'heure
avec monsieur le ministre de l'outre-mer
notamment en occupant le terrain de jeu
si on n'occupe pas le terrain d'autres
le feront à notre place et le font
depuis déjà bien longtemps
et puis amélioré la sélectivité des
outils de la pêche et pour ça je veux
saluer le travail de georges michel
karam président du comité régional des
pêches maritimes de guyane décédé il ya
peu qui a beaucoup contribué à améliorer
les aligner les outils de pêche et les
travaux des marins pêcheurs guyanais